did you see aoc goes to a dinner that's
thirty to thirty five thousand dollars
ahead
and she wears a dress
she wears a dress saying tax the rich
after partying
with the rich she wears this dress
that's a thousand bucks hanging out with
millionaires and billionaires and she
sports this dress saying tax
the rich and people go
bonkers over it what uh what a
noble human being she is is it hypocrisy
what is the word for this
stupidity no first of all i will tell
you what it is number one is genius
marketing okay for her for her i
actually agree i i think it's genius
marketing she's she's a genius when it
comes down to marketing i don't care
what anybody says they're pissed off
because she comes up with these ideas in
the area of marketing you couldn't have
thought about a you couldn't have had a
better person a better marketer for the
message of socialism you couldn't have a
better marketer a a rich girl who
chose to vacation in poverty and gives a
story about i couldn't pay my bills well
because i was bartending in new york
first of all anybody knows anybody who
bartends in new york they make cake all
right that's number one number two yeah
they spend it all on rent so it's not
like they're yeah it's like they're net
worth
rent and other things but the
she couldn't afford
right to live her life because this is
the part of the story that nobody ever
talks about she was spending all day
volunteering on the bernie sanders
campaign
she was she was an unpaid employee for
bernie sanders so she's telling
capitalism was the worst i had to work
and i was i was overqualified and
underpaid because bernie sanders didn't
pay her well enough
she wants to talk like she's jenny from
the block she's jenny from westchester
she went to bu dude stop it with this we
got
as a as a people as a globe we have to
be able to look at something and say
this is basuda this is pure trash enough
of this already
tax the rich 3 500 she spent five
thousand
thousand thirty five thousand dollars
who's 75 per table let me say this again
it's thirty five thousand dollars a
person thirty to thirty five thousand
each table was actually seventy five but
people that are richer than me i'm not
rich i'm just i'm just i'm
don't be don't be don't be fooled by the
rocks that i got i'm just aoc from so
here's here's the question she shows up
there's you know probably a couple
thousand people here
what's the
what's the story line when she shows up
are people shaking her hand are they
giving her a hug if you're a kiss is the
is she is she a rock star there do they
hate her she's sitting in the corner are
people being like we love you like
what's the oh i think what's the
scenario i think those who are holding
up the messaging of uh democrats they
have to agree with her whether that they
like it or not because they're worried
about being cancelled oh my god you're
throwing right here
the fear
the fear of being cancer because here's
how you got to do it so what's what's
more expensive 50 taxes or
losing those three movies what's more
expensive the movie yeah who gives a
[ __ ] about fifty percent i can't lose
that movie at 20 million dollars a pop
ten million dollars of pops i'm like
listen you're amazing you're amazing but
it's a form of control
it is a form of cancer culture the fear
in actors hollywood they're so worried
about it very few of them are willing to
come out and say this woman's lost her
freaking mind because if they do that
they can potentially lose the next job
that's coming out in hollywood everyone
in hollywood's afraid right now except
for some of the guys that are stepping
away saying look we don't give a [ __ ]
what you're going to be doing we're
going to do our own thing we don't need
you guys anymore we're going to do our
own thing yeah i think there's a coup
going on in hollywood as well loki
you've got bernie sanders all right
bernie sanders not one not two but three
houses makes a million dollars
he donates less than one percent of that
less than one percent he donates when he
somebody the one journalist left in
america asks him the questions like so
what would you say to people who who are
are
you know claiming hypocrisy with your
crusade against the rich when you are in
fact rich well
if they wanted to be rich they should
have they should have wrote a book like
oh okay that's that's the answer how
much money has she made off this tax to
rich merch she is the most capitalist in
in dc she's got an entire text great
marketer and i'm going to tell you
what's going to make a hell of a cmo
this is the truth hell of a cmo do you
see this by the way we'd hire her right
now if she could set aside her
socialistic tendencies with her right
now you see this right here this is the
crux of all the issues gentlemen this
right here she's a latina from the bronx
ain't got no booty that is the that's
what's happening here
she needs to she wants to be canceled
she needs to redistribute she saw look
if anybody's ever been in a bx anybody's
ever been uptown there we go you get it
you just got personal bro you got a
dominican or a puerto rican girl they
walk in hips first everywhere they go
she got upset she's mad she's mad this
this is why she she wants a level of
baby
you don't talk
you know it's funny you bring up the
bernie sanders thing and i'm not a fan
of bernie but i will say this if you're
freaking 80 years old and you've been
making i don't know what do you get paid
180 grand a year and you're still and
you don't have any money you know the
house
he's never had a real job but he's only
ever worked off of the government dole
regardless that's his job he's a
parasite whatever he is the point is
this if you're 80 years old and you're
still broke that's probably a bigger
problem at least these guys broke he's
not that's my point he's like to have a
house and to be a millionaire at age 80
is not that big of an accomplishment
congratulations you've
saved 10 percent of your income and i
tell you this you get your benefit same
pension that's not that big of a deal
she has a 10 to 20 percent chance of
being a president in the next 20 years
remember when i said this what are the
chances that she's against gerard's vote
dude the green new deal it's gonna it's
gonna pass yeah like she's winning she's
got ten or twenty percent aoc antoinette
let them eat brunch she doesn't need our
vote by the time by the time she becomes
a good representative let them meet
brunch
the french revolution aoc antoinette
over here i like that
parallelogram you did right there this
is parallels so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you